Al Gore can't defend his Inconvenient
lies Al Gore's Inconvenient sequel comes
as his dire climate predictions fail to
materialize Al Gore can't save the
global warming cult the fake science is
exposed the best way to reduce your
carbon emissions don't be rich
somebody tell Leonardo DiCaprio and Al
Gore Al Gore says ironically the rich
have subverted all reason and from l
magazine this is guaranteed to be fake
news Al Gore is getting hotter gross
Al Gore defender of the planet inventor
of the internet groper of masseuses is
back ten years after his feature-length
fantasy film An Inconvenient Truth
predicted Armageddon in a decade
the former future president brings us an
inconvenient sequel truth to power in
which he steadfastly refuses to correct
all of the inconveniently false
predictions he made in the first movie
we will analyze plus the panel of
deplorable z-- joins us the conservative
millennial Jacob Barry and so Rachel
will discuss Russia expelling US
diplomats potential war with North Korea
and the worst news of all truly
devastating the mooch is out as
communications director I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles
[Music]
devastating news
absolutely devastating out like ten
minutes ago scaramouche II after ten
days on the job is out as the White
House communications director and this
is the first episode of our show can you
believe they gave me a show yeah I think
I'm the first guy in history to get his
own show producer Marshall a job I think
I'm the first guy in history to get his
own show for not writing a book so
that's really great I'm really happy to
have it this show you know it's gonna be
you come for the conversation you stay
for the cafe we've got a great panel
coming up later but first we have to
dive right into Al Gore so let's get
right into it we knew it was coming we
when he made that first movie in 2006
what would you have predicted was more
likely in 10 years or mageddon or Saint
al bringing more money out of this
racket clearly it was the latter
you know it's expensive he's got to pay
for his beachfront property that is
going to be flooded soon I suppose he's
got to pay for all those jets
his house his Tennessee house consumes
between 12 and 20 percent more energy
than the average home so he's got to pay
for all of that carbon offset presumably
but we have a lot to dissect here so
let's let's get right into it I saw it
so that you don't have to let's look at
the beginning of the trailer for an
inconvenience Essure that was from the
movie I can't remember that was from the
movie or somewhere else now that isn't
fair that is not fair we shouldn't be
making fun of our opponents like that by
the way the reason it isn't fair is that
Al Gore would never exaggerate his role
in world history or visit
self-importance I don't think right my
service in the United States at Congress
I took the initiative and creating the
Internet oh gosh that's that doesn't
look good all right well let's get into
the actual trailer of weekend do we have
a go
it's supposed to be 70 degrees today at
freezing here
speaking of global warming where is we
need some global warming freezing the
most criticized scene in the movie An
Inconvenient Truth was showing that the
combination of sea level rise and storm
surge would flood a 9/11 memorial site
and people said what a terrible
exaggeration Hurricane sandy slammed
into New York City last night plotting
the World Trade Center site visit you
have to hand it to Al Gore this guy has
cojones of steel he opens up his trailer
with some of the most stunning hypocrisy
in the entire movie one thing we're
always told by the alarmists
the global warming alarmists is that
weather is not climate so Donald Trump
you saw in that clip he says you know we
need a little bit more global warming
it's a little chilly here and people say
well that's just the weather and the
weather is different than the climate
because the climate is a lot of weather
or something like that but then Al Gore
immediately goes to one weather event
that happened in New York I lived
through it as actually my apartment was
flooded during that storm that wasn't
the worst storm in New York history
there were there have been I think
something like 84 major hurricanes and
cyclones in the last three or 400 years
in New York City that was certainly not
the worst where there's why in 1938
killed 600 people that flattened by the
way Al Gore's claim in his original
movie I don't think it's that every once
in a while parts of New York are going
to flood the streets are going to flood
I think it was that major cities would
be underwater but it is a really
masterful painting over and glossing
over of that first assumption and and
really that stunning apocrypha sets you
up for the rest of the movie let's keep
going on with the trailer talking about
breaking the impasse virtually every
nation in the entire world agreed to get
to zero greenhouse emissions it is
unprecedented
it's time to put America first that
includes the promise to cancel billions
in climate change spending the goal the
unmitigated gall of our president to put
the country that he's the president of
before all of the other countries in the
world can you believe it it's
unimaginable but you know there are a
lot of things that the rest of the world
does in America doesn't do that are
pretty good you know the rest of the
world does play soccer we don't do that
and that seems just fine rest of the
world has abandoned the Christian roots
of Western civilization I'm pretty glad
that we've we've managed to keep doing
that the rest of the world abridges the
liberty of its citizens even in the
Anglosphere even in the United Kingdom
if you say something that's politically
incorrect if you make comments about
Islam or other religions or political
ideas you can be arrested for doing just
that the United States has done quite a
lot of things on its own and avoided a
lot of the conflicts and troubles that
the rest of the world has but he takes
another pot shot at Trump this trailer
might as well be the the Donald Trump
trailer it is totally a reaction to it
and probably Al Gore thought that he
could make a little bit of money by
tying it into the news but alas alas
nobody nobody has been going to see this
movie let's let's go into we have more
this trailer generation would be
justified in looking back at us and
asking what were you thinking couldn't
you hear what the scientists were saying
couldn't you hear what Mother Nature was
screaming at you
it's in the tradition of every great
movement that has advanced human color
it is right to save humanity it is wrong
to pollute this earth it is right to
give hope to the future gentlemen I do
not hear Mother Nature screaming at me I
hear Al Gore screaming at me it's very
unpleasant and is that this is the sort
of sad thing about this movie after I
saw it actually tweeted out that I
genuinely almost felt sorry for Al Gore
because as you saw he doesn't really
take on the criticisms from his first
movie he kind of glides over a couple of
them most of the movie isn't even about
global warming he doesn't really go into
data the movies just about Al Gore Al
Gore taking meetings with people
Al Gore making phone calls to people Al
Gore doing everything he can to stay
relevant but unfortunately it doesn't
seem like people are responding anymore
the trouble with making a movie in which
you predict Armageddon is you have to be
right where you can't make a sequel to
it so I went to see it on opening night
in Los Angeles opening night for this
movie in the left-wing center of the
world it was only playing in two
theaters in LA and not just that I went
with my fiancee to go see it we
constituted 25% of the audience there
were eight people in the whole theater
so I the louder he yells the less people
listen and vice-versa I think do it now
he by the end of this clip he actually
does get to the heart of the matter he
gets to really what what the left-wing
agenda is for this country and what the
environmentalist agenda is can we keep
going
[Music]
I guess we skipped over his oh I
remember it so even though he skipped
over his words what he says are don't
let anybody tell you that we're going to
Mars don't let anybody tell you that
we're gonna colonize someplace else this
world this is our home we're staying
here so we have to stop doing whatever
we have to stop driving our cars and
having nice productive lives
that is the heart of this left-wing
agenda because in the old days this this
is not what we saw we now we're being
told do less drive less produce less
travel less be pollute less you know
there is no positive message that we're
getting out of this this was not always
the case another a Democratic president
someone who actually made it to the
presidency from the Democratic Party had
a very different message even 50 years
ago let's hear it we choose to go to the
moon we choose to go to the moon
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard because that challenge is one
that we are willing to accept one we are
unwilling to postpone and one we intend
we choose to crushed in Cannes we choose
to cut those little plastic things that
hold the cans together so the dolphins
don't choke we choose to crush teen
can't that is the Democratic Party has
come a very long way since from
President Kennedy to Al Gore and it's a
really sad devolution that we're seeing
with them the movie isn't about global
warming one neat little tricky doesn't
it though you've seen the nomenclature
change over time initially in the 70s
and 80s it was global cooling then it
became global warming then it became
climate change when the scientific
observations didn't match up with the
predictions now Al Gore's changed it
again that the phrase he uses constantly
incessantly in the movie is the climate
crisis the climate crisis and this
serves two purposes one it's just as
ambiguous as climate change
so it's unfalsifiable but climate crisis
also means come on everybody listen to
me more come see my movie care about
this he's seen that interest in global
warming has ebbed and receded it
immensely since 2006 so the end is also
pathetic this movie ends like a bad
nonprofit fundraising video they have a
hashtag up on the screen as a tweet this
tweet be inconvenient go to our Facebook
page
it's really really pathetic whatever you
thought of that first I mean the first
movie was nonsensical it was stupid it
was alarmist but it was good propaganda
it was actually a pretty good good work
of propaganda when the Oscar for it I
think he got his Nobel Prize for for his
PowerPoint presentation this is it
really phoned in it's a cheap money grab
and said for him it isn't making any
money so before before you rush out to
the sequel after that great
recommendation there are some
Corrections from the first movie that he
does not address in this movie you would
think you take the opportunity but he
doesn't so we've all heard about a lot
of the scandals and East Anglia
University the United Nations climate
scientists
caught manipulating data trying to hide
the decline to account for periods in
which warming did not occur over the
past 15 and 20 years the the IPCC I
actually the Internet governmental Panel
on Climate Change did admit in a draft
its 2013 report that there a lot of
their predictions haven't come true so
they were at least a little bit more
forthright than climate evangelist Al
Gore but in 2007 so just shortly after
the movie came out the British High
Court identified nine errors in the
movie that we're so egregious that if
you showed the movie to schoolchildren
in the UK you actually had to read a
disclaimer this is one case where he
needed a trigger warning because there
are so many falsities in the movie that
we had to correct them so and since then
we've seen that many other predictions
from the film haven't come true but
let's just go through them really
quickly so that you can be prepared when
you become the fifth person to go see Al
Gore's Inconvenient sequel so in the
movie
Al Gore predicted a 20-foot sea-level
rise in the near future the judge in
that 2007 decision said the Armageddon
scenarios he predicts insofar as it
suggests that sea level rises of seven
metres might occur in the immediate
future is not in line with the
scientific consensus so much for that
scientific consensus the 97% 150 percent
of scientists that think Al Gore should
have been president or something like
that I don't remember what the exact
study was the second the Pacific atolls
quote or being inundated because of
anthropogenic global warming was a claim
made in the movie there isn't there is
no evidence of that there's no evidence
of evacuations happening there it was
just made up whole cloth number three
global warming would shut down the Gulf
Stream the the stream between the
continental Europe and the UK and the
east coast of the United States even the
UN climate panel said that that was
unlikely that was the UN climate panel
said that been unlikely before Al Gore
made his movie but he put it in there
anyway I guess he spends a good yarn it
makes for a for a good film then the
film also showed an exact fit between
carbon dioxide level rises and
temperature level rises but the data
don't bear that out the judge pointed
this out there is some scientific
consensus that there is a relationship
between the
but a one-to-one direct line there is no
evidence that that exists
Al Gore staked a lot of his ridiculous
film on it and then Kilimanjaro the
snows of Kilimanjaro mr. Gore predicted
in 2006 that the snows of Kilimanjaro
would be gone within 10 years Marshall
have used have you seen it lately have
you looked at anything you're like you
haven't pulled out there's there's snow
still on there that's not from ten years
ago there are still snows on Kilimanjaro
how wonderful for Mother Nature how sad
for Al Gore another another prediction
similar is that Lake Chad is drying up
because of global warming this one is a
little trickier because Lake Chad
actually is drying up depending on the
season and over time but there is no
evidence that it's caused by man-made
global warming this is what's really
hard to where people say a little bit of
knowledge is a dangerous thing whenever
anything happens in the environment
nobody knows anything about
environmental science including myself
but because this has become such a
political issue any time it's a
partially cloudy day in Los Angeles the
the mass populace will attribute it to
global warming and there isn't evidence
for a lot of these things so with the
drying up of Lake Chad there are a lot
of other reasons that have been proposed
there's been a massive population
increase there's been there's grazing
and there's also regional climate
variability so not not all climate
variability is due to some global
phenomenon or man-caused pollution
places change over time and there's much
more evidence that that's what's causing
the lake chad dry up then you're driving
your SUVs Hurricane Katrina Al Gore said
that Hurricane Katrina shows the effects
of global warming and this is another
incredible evidence where weather is not
climate and climate is not weather
except when it's convenient for Al Gore
yes then then there's a one-to-one
correlation but when conservatives say
that it's ridiculous you're uneducated
you're rubes there is there is no
evidence that Hurricane Katrina was
caused by global warming there is a lot
of evidence that Hurricane Katrina and
the devastation that it wrought is
caused by insufficient levies and bad
Democrat municipal leadership there is a
city that's been run by Democrats for
ever and they didn't prepare for four
these potential disasters not a lot of
evidence again that your SUV cause that
that terrible disaster and then the
polar bears those poor don't you
remember after that movie came out there
were all these memes going around that
one that lone polar bear on a little
floating ice sheet because all of his
pals had drowned the they were in danger
of going extinct that all the ice was
melting so they were swimming and
drowning there is just three numbers
that we should read off that will that
will disabuse you of this notion that Al
Gore were propagating his film in 1960
Jean how many polar bears there were in
the world estimated eight to ten
thousand polar bears in the world that
is in danger of extinction now in 2005
just before Al Gore made his movie 45
years after 1960 there is an estimated
25 20 to 25,000 polar bears in existence
that's pretty good don't call it a
comeback that's a that's a great
increase since the 1960s but what about
10 years later there have to be what 5
or 10 polar bears left in the world not
true the polar bear population is now
estimated between 23 and 32 thousand
polar bears great news for the polar
bears I'm so happy to see that bad news
for Al Gore and his first movie and his
sequel and then finally Al Gore claimed
that the coral reef would be bleached
and destroyed by global warming but
again there is insufficient evidence of
this there's insufficient evidence that
the coral reefs haven't adapted and we
still have plenty of reefs to go around
and snorkel and scuba dive by so with
that let's bring in our panel of
deplorable z' we have we have a truly
truly deplorable panel today we have
from the blaze and the conservative
millennial vlog we have Allie Stuckey
the conservative millennial from PJTV
and about a gazillion other media
outlets we have Alfonso zou Rachael and
from the alley next to the Chatsworth
psychiatric hospital we have Jacob Airy
thank you all for joining us today let's
go right into Al Gore's so why are we
wasting so much time talking about
healthcare and Isis and the North Korea
crisis when we could be talking about
the Sun monster the Sun monster's gonna
kill us all
and Mayor bear big that's a great point
I should have reconsidered my thoughts
that is an x-rated way to begin the
Michael Nolan show going right into Al
Gore transgender change and he's decided
represent himself as a mother earth and
and if you really care about the
environment I don't think you would be
encouraging people you know to waste
their gas money and waste gas and
emissions one CD is moving that is a
great point Jacob if we just count a few
more Chad's out of those counties in
Florida do you think Al Gore can finally
be President that's what this is all
about right it's just sixteen seventeen
years later he can't get over it I know
and what's crazy about it is Al Gore
when he when he won his Nobel Peace
Prize for doing this slide show there
was people there were people who
actually deserved it there was a lady
who was proposed by a holocaust
organization her name was Irena Sendler
and she actually rescued 2,500 children
Jewish children in Poland during the
Nazi occupation and she lost to Al Gore
who did a video that has largely been
despont receiving debunked so I honestly
think that even if we got rid of all
those all those rednecks who who just
want to drive their their Ford f-150s I
still think Al Gore would lose in the
long run
typical right-wing propaganda you think
that some some hero of the Holocaust
deserves a prize more than Al Gore who
told us to crush tin cans absolutely
disgusting hate speech ally do
millennials care about global warming or
is this just some baby boomer hippie
dippie fantasy unfortunately we're duped
by things that we scroll on past on
Facebook sensationalized headlines and
so if you're someone who is easily duped
then maybe you could go to something
like this and actually
I believe that the world is coming to an
end but if Millennials actually stepped
back and thought about the fact that Al
Gore is saying that our quality of life
is lowering that life expectancy is
lowering because of fossil fuels and
they actually thought about the fact
that the opposite is true that the
quality of life has become better that
life expectancy has lengthened even
while we're using more and more fossil
fuels then maybe they would see that
what he's telling isn't the entire
picture and if Al Gore really cared
about people the seven billion people in
the world their access to clean water
their quality of life you would actually
be pushing fossil fuels but he's not
he's doing the opposite so anyone that
doesn't see this as propaganda
Millennials are not sadly they're quite
a problem to quote a great man's sad the
speaking of gullible fools there is this
really creepy aspect to the movie where
the last third of it shows him going
around to these cult-like gatherings and
he's teaching them he calls them his
global warming trainings or his climate
crisis trainings and you see all of
these little clerics of the global
warming religion learning from their
their Pope their high priest so is that
what this is is that what this is about
just secular religion and and gullible
fools well I'm getting a bad
transmission but I think it might if I
could try to piece together what you see
because I did hear I heard the magic
word of religion that's what I think
this whole thing is I think it stays
sponsored religion as it is but yeah
this he is preying on the
self-righteousness of these Millennials
and by little Baptists boos because of
all this global warming stuff these
people have these these kids are having
to pay some awful gas prices I feel you
know you guys first get your driver's
license you ready to hit the road and
take off the gas you guys got to pay
these high gas prices that's really that
really sucks it's because of people like
Al Gore that we have to pay these high
gas prices for all these boutique fuels
and all these regulations that they put
on these taxes that they put on fuels
preaching this fear-mongering that they
do I blame Bush and the Russians but
agree to disagree agree to disagree we
have to go now and sign off of Facebook
and YouTube because you all who don't
subscribe to The Daily wire can't keep
watching it costs $10 a month or $100 a
year and you get the rest of this
absolutely deplorable panel but we're
gonna be talking about scare Moochie
you talking about all the news but you
can't see it unless you subscribe so go
to the daily wire right now
subscribe you'll get the Michael Dahl
show the Ben Shapiro show the Andrew
Clavin show and a lot of other perks so
go over there right now and Facebook and
YouTube we'll see you later
you
okay so we have news now that Russia
will expel 755 US diplomats in
retaliation to new sanctions that we've
passed here we we actually have video
footage of our weak corrupt president
colluding with the Russians do we have
[Music]
that wasn't a new pray that was the weak
and corrupt President Barack Obama okay
interesting well things don't look good
in the us-russia relationship or maybe
that's exactly what Trump wants us to
think Ally can we finally drop this
Russia collusion narrative is it over
finally what do they want they want
stuff to be impeached I don't really
know I don't think it's gonna be over
but frankly I don't think that's that
much of the story yes there's tension
between the US Russia but what else is
new all he's doing is dialing the number
of diplomats back to what it was before
755 diplomats in Russia is actually a
huge number I think the only have 50
Russian diplomats in America so he's
just yelling it back this is uh you know
political take four attack it's not that
big of a deal honestly Jacob or the US
and Russia headed for conflict right now
or has Trump ushered in an actual
Russian reset which Hillary Clinton
tried to do and mistranslated the word
is this a big nothing burger or are we
headed for are we headed for conflict
we've always been in conflict with
Russia so I honestly think it's just a
big nothing burger I agree with ally
it's just business as usual he did the
same thing when during the Obama
administration when Obama shut down some
of their embassies that that's all this
is it's just him trying to say hey look
at me I'd on a horse with no shirt on
that's all that Putin is doing right now
so you know we haven't had a war in a
while it's been all of our wars have
kind of been winding down
can we get can we get this one should
there are we how are the Democrats gonna
spin this and how are we gonna finally
get some war over here I tell you what
man I usually
popular thing the popular saying is we
need a ward increase our economy as far
as I remember we didn't work for a
little while and I don't see people
feeling all that great about the economy
but we talk about the world with today
we talk about a North Korea is that the
one hey you know that eight that's a
great I don't doc huh you know and by
the way you know Kim's our listen here
you don't want to mess with us too much
you know because Americans we love
barbecue and we here to career barbecue
is really good so uh you know if you
don't want to be on our grill you don't
slow you know I'm glad you brought that
up
we actually have live footage right now
we have a live feed into Pyongyang as
tensions ramp up with North Korea can we
ping into that
[Music]
No
and so I'm a bit around REE
[Music]
incredible footage incredible footage
this is what you subscribe to the daily
wire for Jacob shouldn't we just be a
little bit more compassionate and
accommodating of the Kim regime aren't
they just a little bit lonely oh
absolutely not we need to keep our our
hammer on that we need to be watching
them they are up to no good and these
missile tests show this I'm not
advocating we should and do an invasion
or anything but we should definitely
keep a sharp eye on them they are always
trying something new to to cancel out
democracy because they want to spread
their red terror wherever they go have
you no empathy you monstrous Republican
ally the Kim regime has really been
aggressive lately they've been shooting
off a lot of missiles one missile very
close to Japan what does Kim jong-un
think that he has to gain from this
what's his endgame here which is what he
thinks will be absolute power now
whether his idea of how much power he
actually hasn't completed because he is
so isolated and lonely we don't really
know but that's why exactly what we just
heard is that Trump needs to keep a
sharp eye on him and put pressure on
China and that's exactly what he's doing
he's calling out China for not keeping
these things at bay which is absolutely
true I don't think that we can any
longer trust China doesn't help us in
that department you mispronounced it it
is China but otherwise great points I
totally agree
so is president Trump gonna blow up the
world or has his handling of
international affairs been pretty
reassuring the world I think that's a
great that's really all you have to say
about it that's that's a really great
point we got we're gonna make that into
an article brilliant brilliant
this there is he's blown up his White
House he's blown up all of my excitement
about this White House because of the
terrible news that came out just 20
minutes ago Anthony scaramouch II the
mooch Wall Street executive White House
communications director he is out from
his post after just 10 days to quote a
great man sad
the mooch got rights fired Rice's
replacement got the mooch fired Ali is
this chaos narrative correct is that
what's going is this total chaos or is
there any strategy here in entrusting
reporter which he never should have done
he said some things he probably didn't
mean but he said and I think for a
communications director that wasn't
really good luck so I actually commend
Trump first and you know what none of
this nonsense I think he's actually
cutting out some chaos by firing someone
who otherwise would have done a good job
but just messed up I don't think you
have any room for this kind of
tomfoolery anymore so that's why they
had to say sorry sir me too you're out I
guess that's true you know whenever I'm
having a little fight with my fiancee or
I'm I'm arguing with the Daily wire
god-king jeremy boring the first thing I
do is call up left-wing reporter Ryan
Lizza at The New Yorker that's the first
thing I do I said you know Ryan I'm
sorry I got to take my call again I'm
just really upset at all of my friends
and colleagues and he it's it's too bad
it didn't work out for scaramouche II
you know George Steinbrenner very
famously fired all of his top employees
over and over again II rehire them he'd
fire them again and he is the winningest
owner in baseball history though is
Trump's revolving door a sign of
adaptability and strength or does it
bode badly for the Trump administration
from what I can get from that and and I
could use some of that Trump money so I
can upload a bit are you a better signal
amplifier or something once we get those
better trade deals then the economy's
gonna boom we'll be able to get you a
better signal that's that's bad I kept a
job longer so but hey but you know if
you go to the fire thing you know we
gotta we gotta get those beams forward
Trump a cycle on your fire he's got to
come on Twitter and say you're fired or
something like that and and and I'm
ready to sure whose farm who she was
fired by was he fired by his wife he
also he also was fired by his face I was
getting a divorce he worked for
President Trump just long enough to get
divorced
not a good tenure hey right
and I'm sorry from stepping on the
bigness like my Chancellor said that but
I think I think scar Moochie may have a
career as a rap artist man because he
uses more foul language than any rap
I've ever heard that is a great advice I
hope that the mooch is watching really
good advice from so you should you
should take it down Jacob
Sean Spicer has got to be feeling great
right now that he had the second
shortest tenure of any press secretary
in US history and he still lasted six
seven months skier Moochie gone after
only ten days why did he only last a
week was it was it that New Yorker
article or was it did he unexpectedly
hire the man who was gonna fire him well
or what were the workings like I
honestly think it was tension between
him and the new White House chief of
staff John Kelly former Marine general
the the rumor was that
scaramouche II was bragging that he had
unlimited access to Trump that he could
go right around Kelly and go straight to
the Oval Office and reports are saying
that at the beginning of the week are
just yesterday Kelly told the staff no I
am in charge I am running things I'm the
chief of staff no one goes through goes
through me
our goes to trump through me and so I
really think I really think that that's
what this was was scary scary mooshi
wanted unlimited access and Kelly was
like not happening that's that's my
honest take on this whole thing I think
he might have been a victim of global
warming but who knows who knows it'll be
for us to debate thank you all for being
here Ali's Oh Jacob great to have you
I'm sure we'll have you back now get out
of here what a deplorable panel what a
deplorable panel that is now it is time
for the final thought
[Music]
global warming evokes a religious
passion particularly among the secular
left not merely because it
coincidentally justifies every policy
goal they've harbored for a century but
even more because it offers atheists the
satisfaction of their natural religious
longings climate change is unfalsifiable
as evidenced by the ever-changing
nomenclature global cooling global
warming the catch-all climate change and
now Al Gore's even more mealy-mouthed
climate crisis this quasi religion
offers sin in pollution redemption in
recycling even the sale of indulgences
in carbon offset credits fantasies of
imminent carbon induced Armageddon are
secular eschatology and Al Gore is a
modern-day millerite but st. Allen his
apostles would do well to ask themselves
a sobering question how would you Rio
reinter life if the world doesn't
actually need your saving I'm Michael
Knowles this is the first episode of the
Michael Noel's show come back tomorrow
we'll do it again
[Music]
you
[Music]